I sense it.
the jedi fell a
Long time ago.
There aren't many left.
Perhaps it is time to begin again.
Thrawn’s returned
as heir to the Empire.
Welcome back everyone
This is the way. They
released a second longer a soldier trailer
with way more footage and reveals,
including a better shot of what
Thrawn is actually going to look like.
They didn't post it
online, Sought to be kind of careful
about the way I break this down,
but there's a ton more Easter eggs
that were not in the regular Ahsoka
trailer video that I did last week.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing videos
for all the Ahsoka episodes
when it premieres.
Be sure to subscribe to get them all.
The Mandalorian and Season
three finale is going to happen next week,
so of course I'll be doing videos
for that as well.
They'll actually be using that finale
episode to set up the Ahsoka episodes
a little bit more
to lots of cameos coming,
lots of stuff that's going to be happening
during the Ahsoka series
that they want to tease.
Grand Admiral Throne's return will herald
in the reemergence
of our military cheaply.
Among those everything that's going on
with Thrawn that they just started teasing
that in The Mandalorian Season
three Episode seven So you can kind of
see how things are falling into place
as we head into the Ahsoka episodes.
It's all meant to be building
towards the Heir to the Empire movie
that they're doing with Thrawn
as the main villain.
But the extended trailer starts
with a different scene of Ahsoka
at that same ancient Jedi temple ruins.
She starts the trailer with the same
voiceover saying Something is coming.
So the voiceover,
during the extended version,
the trailer that they didn't post
online is the same voiceover
from the regular trailer.
It's just different footage.
But then there's a longer scene
from inside the lower level of the temple
ruins as she uses her twin lightsabers
to cut a hole into that chamber.
You see different formations
rising out of the ground
and it makes it seem like this
lower chamber is the same place
where she's fighting Balan's skull.
The other dark Jedi.
Later in the trailer where you see
the force energy rippling around them
and it looks kind of like the same symbols
from the world between worlds,
like they're inside a version of the world
between worlds,
or they're trying to enter the world
between worlds.
Dave Filoni also confirmed
what's going on with Baylan Skoll
and the other Dark Jedi's lightsabers.
He did say that they were meant to look
a little bit orange, like not pure red.
They also revealed
that her name is Shin Hati.
He said he wanted the color
of their lightsabers to be near red,
but not pure red.
And it was supposed to mean two things.
One, it was
meant to be a callback to Darth Vader's
Sith lightsaber in the original trilogy
during those movies,
because of the technology
that George Lucas had available at the
time to do Darth Vader's Red lightsaber.
The color wasn't always 100% accurate red,
so sometimes the color would appear
to be a little bit orange,
but not because they intended it
to be that way at the time.
Now, cut to present day Dave Filoni,
who's known for recontextualizing
old details and errors
from the original trilogy,
like little editing errors
or like a little background things
that you wouldn't think
too much of at the time.
Back in the seventies, in the eighties
when these movies actually happened.
But in present day, he reinterprets them
in a way that makes them seem even cooler,
he said.
Now, in present day,
what used to just be a technological error
in the filming
the color correction process,
now they're saying the reason Darth Vader
Sith lightsaber appears orangish
sometimes is because he had always felt
the pull of the light side of the force,
shifting the color of his kyber crystal
and his lightsaber
away from pure sith red.
That's Dave Filoni for you.
He does stuff like that all the time.
He's also the person that really canonized
Thrawn during Star Wars rebels too.
On the Ahsoka series though, it's
the same idea with these new Dark Jedi
and Skull and Shin Hate.
They're not meant to be traditional Sith
Dark Jedi like the Emperor or Darth Vader,
but they're not light side
Jedi either, or even gray Jedi either.
He said they're meant to be something new
we haven't seen in the live action
Star Wars movies and series before.
But because he pulls so much from Star
Wars legends and expanded universe stuff,
I think that there'll be something
from deep canon that we haven't heard
about in a long, long time.
I'll probably do a longer video
about those two characters really soon,
just because there's
a whole lot going on with them.
Dave Filoni said he wanted
the trailer footage
then to be kind of mysterious
and people to ask a lot of questions
like What is going on here?
The next trailer footage
is of Thrawn himself,
like a full on face shot
that everybody's been asking for.
It's a new version of Ahsoka, seen
where she's telling someone else
about Thrawn return as heir to the Empire,
dropping that big Easter egg reference
to the original Thrawn trilogy.
Everybody who read those books
all pointing at the screen,
doing the Leonardo DiCaprio meme
during the new version of the scene.
Here in the second trailer
you see Thrawn personal craft landing
on one of the new ships that he has
with him exiting where you see his face.
And it's meant to be a callback
to the scenes of Darth Vader
arriving on his shuttle
in Return of the Jedi
and then Emperor Palpatine arriving,
doing the exact same thing
like it's Thrawn arriving with the same
vibe, like the boss has just arrived.
Everybody crapped their pants.
But their heads have a few
different features from regular humans
in the red coloration of his eyes
looks way more accurate.
You also notice the shift that he arrives
on is very different.
It's not the standard Lambda
class shuttles
that they used to get around
during the original trilogy,
even during the events of The Mandalorian,
because Ahsoka is meant
to happen around the same time
period is the Mandalorian episodes in?
Not That Much time has gone
by since the end of Return of the Jedi.
Like in present day,
we're about nine years
after Return of the Jedi,
and we just saw the ruins of another land
class shuttle on The Mandalorian
that Moff Gideon escaped from.
So there's still in heavy
use around the regular galaxy.
My only theory is
they'll just say that Theron's shuttle
is something that he picked up
while he was stuck in the unknown regions.
And that's
why it's
a completely different type of craft
That's also meant to be the same idea
with these three giant capital ships
that he has to like.
He picked these up in the unknown regions.
Then there's another new scene
people were going crazy
about right after this was Sabine Wren
igniting Ezra Bridgers green light saber
and getting ready to have a big lightsaber
fight with Shin Hatty,
who ignites her orange light saber.
The architecture around them
makes it seem like she's
still somewhere on low Thor
when this fight is happening.
The reason why Sabine has Ezra's
lightsaber isn't because they found him
and he's back.
He is back, but she has his lightsaber
because before he called the space wheels
the Pergolas goals to take Thrawn seven
fleet
to the unknown regions
at the end of rebels,
he gave his lightsaber to Chopper,
which is meant to be a bit of a callback
to Luke Skywalker,
giving his lightsaber to R2-D2.
And it just
seems like since the end of Rebels Chopper
has stayed with Sabine this whole time,
so she's had access to Ezra's lightsaber.
There's also a scene of the New Jedi
Droid, played by David Tennant.
He's meant to be the exact same Jedi
droid from the Jedi ship in Clone Wars.
The scene of him, I believe,
is meant to be on a soldier ship.
There might be flashbacks
with this character too.
A long time ago, when the circle was young
during the events of the prequels
because Hayden Christensen
is also supposed to have some cameo scenes
and we had some Anakin Skywalker
flashback scenes during the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series,
so they might have a similar type of scene
with him in Ahsoka
because Ahsoka was his Padawan.
You also remember that the Jedi Droid
is meant to be about a thousand years old
in present day, so he's older than Yoda
and he has access to the designs
of every single lightsaber
that has ever been constructed
by the Jedi,
which means that at some point
he would have helped Yoda,
like a very young version of Yoda,
go to ILM, select his Kyber crystal
and build his lightsaber,
which now rest with Luke Skywalker,
who almost wound up giving it to grow goo.
So like the circle of Easter
eggs is now complete. This
is a lightsaber
that belonged to my teacher, Master Yoda.
Then there's a longer space battle scene
of a soldier dog fighting with Zeenat
in her Starfighter.
But in the New version of the scene, Shine
Hattie is wearing the special Jedi armor
covering her face.
It looks pretty hardcore.
It kind of looks like samurai armor.
And because we have this new shot of her
in the armor, we can also say that
Ahsoka is fighting her leader
in this scene,
too, with the double bladed lightsaber
because it seemed like a different person
at the time.
And if you notice her lightsaber hilt,
it looks a lot like an inquisitors
lightsaber hilt like the lightsaber
looks like an inquisitors lightsaber.
So she might have some connection
with the Inquisitor.
It's like maybe during the events
of the original trilogy
she was being trained by the inquisitors
to become another inquisitor.
And then Balon School found her.
Or she found him after the destruction
of the Second Death Star.
Then there's a longer live action
version of the scene.
From the end of Star
Wars, Rebels were Sabina's touching
the mural of the ghost crew on Little
before Issac arrives to get her help.
The difference
a lot of people have noticed
with this live action version of the scene
is that Sabine's here in the live action
version is longer,
and in the Rebels version it's short.
We do see her in her Mandalorian armor
with the short hair,
so they'll probably say
that the short hair
was just her cutting it
after Ahsoka came to get her in while
she'd been waiting all this time,
she just let it grow out.
So during the rest of the episodes,
her hair will be short again
as it was during Rebels.
The other funny thing about this
mural scene from the end of Rebels
you probably noticed,
is that even though the scene is meant
to be happening in live action,
the art for the mural is still painted
in the exact same style as the style of
Star Wars Rebels animated series.
But if you didn't watch those Rebels
episodes,
the mural was meant to be painted
by Sabine like this is her artwork
she graffitied over everything
during Star Wars rebels
like all over the Ghost Ship,
all over her own armor.
That's why her Mandalorian armor
looks so different from other
traditional mandalorians armor
like Mando's Beskar armor.
During the other trailer scenes.
We have slightly better footage of you
actually seeing the background.
She's graffitied like a lone wolf here,
like the Force Wolves.
So she graffiti is all over the place.
They have a new scene of Sabine
still on Luther,
but riding a speeder bike,
which seems like her regular bike
because it's painted purple
with a bunch of highlights,
like it's painted to look as if Sabine
already changed
the color in the scene is also meant
to be a callback to the scene of Ahsoka
doing the same thing
when she first came back
during the final season of Clone Wars.
Then at the end of the trailer,
there's actually a pretty cool
Easter egg shot here.
You see Sabine and Ahsoka on Ahsoka's ship
while she's wearing her
Mandalorian armor
flying past a giant pergola.
The space whales from Star Wars rebels,
which we just saw
during the Mandalorian season
3 episode 1.
Like the joke that they end the trailer
on, is it
the space whales going to eat her ship
unless she swerves to avoid it
and it's also meant to be a sign
that Thrawn in As Rebels are back
as it was the beginning
of the Mandalorian Season three.
What they'll probably do is they'll wait
till we get a little bit closer
to Ahsoka coming out,
or at least another month or two
before they release this new version,
the trailer online.
So if we get more footage before then,
of course I'll do a video for it
and I have a couple other
big Ahsoka videos planned,
like about those dark Jedi baylan
shin hati. My Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode eight Finale Video
We'll post
next week after they release it,
And I have a couple
other bonus videos planned this week too,
so if you have any special request
or big questions about what's happening
with the characters on The Mandalorian
or Ahsoka,
just write them in the comments below.
Everyone
click here to My Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 8 Finale Video
and click here for all my trailer
videos from Star Wars Celebration
for all the new upcoming series.
Thank you so much for watching,
everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.